let's not forget that the entire machine
did this right so this wasn't just the
expert class of Bill Gates and Anthony
fauci that did this the entire corporate
machine tried to scare the hell out of
you and make you hate people that's what
they tried to do more than anything else
this clip was going viral yesterday
here's a joke that Jimmy Kimmel made
about a year ago Jimmy Kimmel and jokes
two things that should not be said in
the same sentence Dr fauci said that if
hospitals get any more overcrowded
they're going to have to make some very
tough choices about who gets an ICU but
out of that choice doesn't seem so tough
to me vaccinated person having a heart
attack yes come right on him we'll take
care of you unvaccinated guy who gobbled
horses goo rest in peace Wheezy you're
that's
I mean
we've still got a lot of
pan dimwits out there all right so just
on the base level it's just vile it's
just vile people made decisions for
themselves actually the people who
decided not to get vaxed I know many
many many many many many many people who
decided not to get backs and none of
them regret it they're feeling pretty
good these days because now it's turning
out that it did not work and people are
in all sorts of side effects and and
just the idea that the government was
forcing you to do this and everything
else it's also interesting there that
the the 35 writers or however many
writers he have that the joke that they
came up with was oh vaccinated person
having a heart attack yeah that is one
of the side effects and Florida just did
a study and males 18 to 35 are having
something like an 84 percent increase in
heart related issues uh so uh that's
kind of that's that's a tough one there
Jimmy but just the vileness of it the
vileness of of no we are not going to
take care of a certain amount of people
right that you would make a joke that
would imply that doctors should be
making decisions based on things of that
nature it's just it's absolutely
disgusting